back in the temporal world it is day
four of the democratic national
convention it is time to consider what
we have learned
so far we've seen an awful lot this week
we watched elizabeth warren promise to
bring
peace to indian country we saw a lady
call in from her 11 million dollar
summer home in martha's vineyard and
claimed to be oppressed
we met a gender trans transcendent
mermaid queen king who
dreamt of a world without police or
prisons we saw a post makeover sandy
cortez
nominate a man she referred to
mysteriously as bernard
sanders for president we've seen a lot
this week
what does it all mean well one thing it
definitely does not amount to is a
coherent ideological framework or a
logical governing strategy
john kasich and sandy cortez may both
have decided to vote for joe biden
but that's about the only thing they
agree on joe biden himself doesn't have
particularly strong views on anything
these days
except maybe lunch in a nap and no one
in the room likes kamala harris
so what exactly do all of these people
have in common
they are all unhappy deeply
and personally unhappy tormented at the
most basic level
this is the coalition of the miserable
it's hard to know precisely what went
wrong for these people some of them are
mad at their fathers
for others life didn't turn out in the
way they'd hoped dash dreams the usual
story
it can make people bitter many others
are simply victims of their own
affluence being rich for too long tends
to destroy people from within
particularly when they didn't earn it
they become guilty and restless and
insecure
whatever the cause you could not pick a
more maladjusted group than the speakers
the dnc this week
you wouldn't want these people
babysitting your kids last night
fittingly the schedule included an
appearance by a singer called billy
eilish
islesha is a very talented performer
she's also very young so we don't want
to be cruel here
but the first thing you notice about
billy eilish is that she's very unhappy
she works in the music business maybe
it's not surprising
but whatever she's got going on in her
personal life you don't want to be part
of it and who knows what it's really
about she probably doesn't know
most of us don't really understand what
ails us but for the purposes
of last night's event it doesn't matter
like almost everybody in the democratic
party billy eilish has decided
that donald trump is her core problem
you don't need me to tell you things are
a mess
donald trump is destroying our country
and everything
we care about we need leaders who will
solve
problems like climate change and kovid
not deny them
leaders who will fight against systemic
racism and inequality
it starts with voting against donald
trump and
for joe biden we all have to vote like
our lives
and the world depend on it because they
do
donald trump is destroying everything we
care about
period that right there is the message
of the dnc this week the message is not
joe biden can identify his own wife by
sight and is therefore fit to leave the
country
no it's not kamala harris is actually a
very sincere person who's really thought
through the issues that matter
no it's not even vote for us and our
program will make the country better
no it's not in fact it's simpler than
that and therefore may be more
compelling
it's you're unhappy so are we it's all
donald trump's fault let's kick him out
and honestly you can kind of see the
appeal here real life by contrast is
complicated it's never that obvious
why things go wrong and of course if
we're being honest about it
all of us are implicated in our own
failures to a much greater extent that
we care to admit
but that's the thing at the democratic
national convention
you don't have to admit it you did
nothing wrong
you're blameless it's all donald trump's
fault
watch chief warren live from indian
country
donald trump's ignorance and
incompetence
have always been a danger to our country
kovig 19 was trump's biggest test
he failed miserably this
crisis is on donald trump and the
republicans who enable him
on november 3rd we will hold them all
accountable see add the coronavirus to
the list of his crimes it's all there
when he wasn't stuffing your
neighborhood's mailboxes into the back
of his suburban
it turns out donald trump was up late in
his basement lab mixing up lethal bat
pathogens
which he then mercilessly unleashed on
america from his own personal wet market
you should see what he did to the
nursing homes in the state of new york
it's awful
but if nothing else give that man points
for energy
donald trump is so committed to making
you unhappy
that he rarely sleeps okay you look
skeptical
how could one man achieve so much global
evil
in a single 24-hour day there's just in
time when did he have a chance to call
vladimir putin
and that's a fair point it does sound
unlikely on the other hand
it's easier than the alternative
explanations let's say you lost a
presidential election that by any
measure you should have won
your husband was the president you were
up in the polls but in the end it turned
out that you were too entitled
you were too out of touch voters just
didn't like you
it would be hard to admit that to
yourself it would be even harder to
admit it to others
you might just prefer to blame donald
trump he must have cheated
it sounds like something he would do i
wish donald trump knew
how to be a president because america
needs a president right now remember
back in 2016 when trump asked what do
you have to lose
well now we know our health care our
jobs
our loved ones our leadership in the
world
and even our post office don't forget
joe and kamala can win by three million
votes
and still lose take it from me
so we need numbers overwhelming so trump
can't sneak or steal his way to victory
see trump stole it along with the
mailboxes and the pay phones
of course he did donald trump is such a
bad person that the true scope of his
diabolical awfulness is hard to describe
maybe impossible to describe like the
concept of infinity
and in fact maybe it's better not even
to try to describe it it's like when
your grandmother got sick
no one wanted to say exactly what it was
the disease was too scary
trump is that bad the good news is
compared to donald trump
everybody else looks good even the worst
people maybe especially the worst people
and that's the beauty of it
listen to how they're describing teddy
kennedy at the dnc
i've admired joe biden since i was a
senate intern in 1974.
he shared my uncle teddy's commitment to
civil rights
women's rights and working families
uncle teddy's commitment to women's
rights yes
the same uncle teddy who fled the scene
of a drunk driving accident and left a
young woman to drown slowly in the back
seat
the same uncle teddy who for decades
chaired the harvey weinstein school of
dating
compared to donald trump though uncle
teddy was a champion of women
that's their position and you're
starting to see the appeal of the
message are you not
everyone gets off the hook except for
donald trump
and of course people who look like
donald trump they're evil too it's guilt
by resemblance
watch cnn explain it was all about
representation my little melanated
cynical heart my immigrant melanated
woman heart felt so full last night
actually today is today with david and
john is the first time i see a white man
like in
eight hours this you know other than
than joe biden last night and that's
okay
they've had 240 years of representation
they're going to be okay
so this is how bad he is anyone with the
same
skin color as donald trump is repulsive
in fact so disgusting so repugnant to
gaze upon
that even a brief respite from looking
at people like this feels like a
vacation
the cnn anchor is now refreshed as she
just told you it was like a
spa treatment in sedona fetch the hot
towels
give me the cucumbers for my eyes keep
in mind
nothing you just heard is racism no
now of course if you said that about the
cnn anchor obviously it would be racism
you would be fired for it maybe arrested
but the cnn anchor isn't donald trump is
she
no she's not someone who looks like
donald trump
is she no okay so it's fine
just like drowning a woman in a car it
totally depends
was trump around it's all about context
eventually kamala harris took the stage
last night and continued this theme
whatever else we are in the democratic
party and actually we're not going to
tell you what we are you don't need to
know
we are definitely not donald trump and
that's enough
so just vote for us everything will be
fine so i think
we need to ask ourselves why don't they
want us to vote
why is there so much effort to silence
our voices and the answer is because
when we vote things change when we vote
things get better oh there it is right
there
that's the line of the night when we
vote things get better
vote for us and things will get better
she's not telling you how they're going
to get better why would she just vote
put us in power and your life will
instantly improve
that's the promise they're making it's
also the promise they've been making for
decades and for decades people have
believed them
democrats now control nearly every major
population center
in this country so the question is how
are those places doing
have things gotten better in say chicago
or detroit or baltimore or gary or
birmingham or
name the city we're not going to answer
that we're going to leave the reporting
on that to you just google the name of
any major american city
and see how life is looking for the
people who live in those places right
now
they did what they were told they voted
the way kamala harris wanted them to
vote
did life improve that is a fair question
it's the basic question it may be the
only question that matters
democrats hate it when you ask when you
press them they'll let you know that and
this may come as a shock
donald trump is destroying things in
places they've controlled for
generations bill de blasio just said
that the other day
and then they change the subject they're
onto something else often they bring up
a place called selma
selma is a small city in the state of
alabama selma is famous because there
was a consequential civil rights march
there 55 years ago this spring you hear
a lot about the march
but you never hear how the story ended
people in selma voted and good that was
the point of the march
and they voted for democrats how did
that turn out for them
selma is now the poorest city in alabama
it is the most
dangerous place in the state it has the
highest
unemployment rate more than 40 percent
of the people who live in selma
are poor they're in poverty that's a
tragedy
it's amazing there is a city like that
in this country does kamala harris care
has she ever mentioned real life selma
as distinct from
selma the metaphor probably she hasn't
and more to the point what has kamala
harris done to make selma better
come on you know the answer progressive
democrats took control of selma
and that was the end of the story
because taking control
was the whole point the lives of the
actual people
who remained there didn't matter and
they still don't
but to kamala harris this is the
blueprint for the rest of the country
in the excessive use of force by police
and in our broader criminal justice
system
there is no vaccine for racism
we've got to do the work
for george floyd for brianna taylor
for the lives of too many others to name
we've got to do the work to fulfill
that promise of equal justice
under law because here's the thing
none of us are free until
all of us are free
yeah okay what's interesting though is
what kamala harris didn't say
in that speech at no point and we
listened carefully did she mention
any of the people dying as she was
speaking
the beatings for example that took place
the assaults that were going on
as the democratic national convention
progressed
this week they're not important the
other day in manhattan a retired nypd
sergeant was viciously beaten and robbed
on camera we showed you beatings in
portland
cities across the country are falling
apart in real time
take a look at the dnc's after party
this week watch
[Applause]
[Music]
those are real people their lives matter
no matter what they look like no matter
who they voted for no matter what they
believe they're americans their lives
matter
and they're being hurt in some cases
killed but they weren't mentioned
they haven't been mentioned all week at
the democratic national convention why
is that
because the policies they're pushing are
implicated in the violence you're
watching
nor if they mention what's happening in
california right now our biggest state
kamala harris's
home state they're rolling blackouts we
need a green new
deal the democrats tell you okay what
will that look like
well there is one state in the union
that is closer to a green new deal than
any other it's california
and thanks to its green energy policy
california is now suffering historic
power outages in the middle of a heat
wave
by the way that can kill people for
another thing
it's not a first world situation we're
supposed to have electricity
and when our biggest state doesn't it
tells you there's been massive and
profound
possibly criminal mismanagement who did
that and why
shouldn't be interested in finding out
no mention of it last night
well we've been without power 60 plus
hours
since friday night inside carl whitley's
home at least half a dozen
medical devices that need power all of
them helped to keep his son
alive during other power outages he
would get advanced notice from pg
e but not this weekend this particular
outage we got
no heads up got no information thousands
of residents in san jose lost power over
the weekend as early as friday night
this map shows that thousands more are
still affected
look most voters in california are
democrats this is not in any sense a
partisan
point california will vote for kamala
harris in november there's no question
about that
it's a question of helping actual people
not just repeating mindless platitudes
telling us the same
two stories about police brutality
nobody defends police brutality nobody's
in favor of it
but if you keep talking about the same
two stories it gives us the sense that
you're
intentionally ignoring what's actually
happening
which is the consistent lowering of the
standard of living
for actual americans millions of them
so you shouldn't be surprised if you
continue to ignore things people
actually care about
the people may not be that excited about
your candidacy despite how they feel
about the guy you're running against
in the case of kamala harris that meant
they had to
make people up take a look at this
this is the banner behind kamala harris
they had to duplicate some of her fans
after the address
it was hard to find a room full of
people actually clapping so they just
invented some people
out of thin air if it's good enough for
major league baseball it's good enough
for the dnc
take a look
so if you're wondering where the genuine
supporters are they may be
wandering around looking for an actual
message
trump bad even if you agree with that
it's a little thin after a while